WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange appeared
on an episode of The Simpsons.
He recorded his lines over the phone from
the Ecuadorian embassy in Britain, where he
has been granted asylum.
The use of the English word 'gay' to mean
homosexual is older than the use of the term
'homosexual' to mean gay.
An octopus can ooze through an opening no
bigger than its own eyeball.
Traffic in central London moves at the same
speed as horse-drawn carriages a century ago.
People are 1% shorter in the evening than
they are in the morning.
The average lifespan of a taste bud is 10
days.
1 in 5 of the world's doctors are Russian.
Beavers have transparent eyelids so they can
see underwater with their eyes shut.
A group of crows is called a murder.
As an apple falls to Earth, the Earth falls
very, very slightly towards the apple.
The first bomb the Allies dropped on Berlin
in WWII killed the only elephant in the Berlin
Zoo.
Every electron in the universe knows about
the state of every other electron, no matter
how far apart they are.
They are all connected by the electromagnetic
field which has infinite range.
Ketchup was sold in the 1830s as medicine.
12% of all the Coca-Cola in America is drunk
at breakfast.
In 2012, 22 baby girls in America were named
"Kindle."
In an average year in Britain, trousers cause
twice as many accidents as chainsaws.
Every time a woodpecker's beak hits a tree,
its head is subject to 1,000 times the force
of gravity.